نبدأ هذه الساعة بتطورات جديدة
من إسرائيل حيث علمنا أن
المسؤولين يقترحون صفقة جديدة لصب
القتال في غزة مقابل
إطلاق سراح المزيد من الرهائن الذين تحتجزهم حركة
حماس، وقد نشر محلل السياسة والسياسة الخارجية في سي إن إن،
باراك رافيد، تلك الأخبار بعد
ساعات فقط.  قبل أن يقول إن إسرائيل
اقترحت وقف إطلاق النار من أجل
إطلاق سراح 40 رهينة من
بينهم نساء كبار السن وأولئك الذين
يحتاجون إلى رعاية عاجلة، يقول رابيد إن
الوسطاء القطريين يأخذون الآن هذا الاقتراح
إلى حماس للرد، وتأتي هذه الأخبار
بعد أن اقترح الرئيس الإسرائيلي على
بلاده  ستكون إسرائيل على استعداد للموافقة على
هدنة مؤقتة جديدة مع حماس
مقابل المزيد من
الرهائن. إسرائيل مستعدة لسلطة فلسطينية إنسانية أخرى
ومساعدات إنسانية إضافية من أجل تمكين
إطلاق سراح
الرهائن المضيفين. تأتي هذه التعليقات في الوقت الذي
كان من المتوقع أن يصوت فيه مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة.
بشأن قرار يدعو إلى
وقف الأعمال العدائية في غزة ولكن تم
تأجيل التصويت وتقول المصادر إنه من
المتوقع الآن أن يتم يوم
الأربعاء. ويهدف القرار إلى توصيل
المزيد من المساعدات الإنسانية إلى غزة. ويقول
الدبلوماسيون إن هناك
مفاوضات مكثفة لوضع اللمسات النهائية على القرار الذي
صاغته  مع دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
نقترب الآن من نهاية ما كان
العام الأكثر دموية في
الأراضي الفلسطينية المحتلة، وينبغي أن يكون هذا بمثابة جرس
إنذار مفاده أنه لا يمكن السماح للوضع الراهن
بالاستمرار. انضم إلي الآن من جنوب
غزة، ستيفن رايان، منسق النشر السريع
مع
اللجنة الدولية للصليب الأحمر، أشكركم
جزيل الشكر على التحدث
معنا، لذا أريد أن أبدأ
بهذا التقرير عن عرض جديد من
إسرائيل لوقف القتال في غزة لمدة
أسبوع واحد على الأقل كجزء من صفقة جديدة
للحصول على  هيراس لإطلاق سراح المزيد من الرهائن
مقابل المساعدات الإنسانية والإفراج عن
المزيد من السجناء الفلسطينيين،
ما هو رد فعلك على تلك
الصفقة الإسرائيلية التي يبدو أنها تمت من خلال
وسطاء قطريين ومن المؤكد بالتأكيد من وجهة
نظر اللجنة الدولية
للصليب الأحمر أن أي شيء
سيجلبه؟  بعض الراحة لملايين
الأشخاص الذين يعانون هنا في
غزة هو شيء سيكون موضع
ترحيب كبير بالطبع هذه الاتفاقيات
ليست شيئًا
اللجنة الدولية للصليب الأحمر المتورطة في
هذا شيء بين
طرفي أه في هذا الصراع  وبينما أه
بينما القتال مستمر فإن
المعاناة مستمرة هنا أيضًا، لذا فإن
هذا شيء آمل أن
يجلب بعض الراحة للأشخاص
الموجودين هنا في غزة الآن